bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat ganz klar
ausgeschlossen dass es deutsche
bundeswehrsoldaten in der ukraine geben
wird der wunsch nach einer
flugverbotszone den die ukraine immer
wieder fordern wird auch nicht von
nato-generalsekretär
berg von nato-generalsekretär
stoltenberg erwidert denn das würde
bedeuten dass tatsächlich
nato-kampfflugzeuge in der ukraine
fliegen müssten um russische
kampfflieger abzuschießen und damit wäre
die nato mittendrin wir sind also in
einem dilemma wirtschaftsredakteur
johannes boie ist bei mir im studio
johannes wir wollen helfen mit geld und
auch militärisch aber können wir auch
helfen ja du machst das ist jetzt genau
die entscheidende frage denn was letzte
woche passiert ist also diese woche im
rückblick ist dass bundeskanzler scholz
ich glaube auch gar nicht unter
einbindung sein des gesamten kabinetts
eine 180 grad wende hingelegt hat diese
wende haben wir bei bild auch gefeiert
wir fanden das gut und ich finde es bis
heute richtig dass er gesagt hat
deutschland wird waffen liefern
deutschland wird die eigene
energiepolitik deutlich verändern wird
lng terminals bauen um unabhängigkeit
von russischen öl und gas herzustellen
und deutschland wird sehr eng an der
seite der seiner nato-partner schärfste
sanktion verhängen das war eine
dramatische wende das ist toll dass
deutschland das geschafft hat und sich
mit manchen forderungen sogar an die
spitze der westlichen
alliierten gesetzt hat aber jetzt stellt
sich natürlich die frage inwiefern ist
das denn überhaupt umsetzbar und
wie unsere recherchen zeigen ist es so
dass bis jetzt weiterhin jeden tag
mehrere hundert millionen euro aus der
europäischen union nach russland
überwiesen werden und hier zeigt sich es
ist der erste punkt von gleich mehreren
so einfach ist das eben gar nicht
umsetzbar für unser land wir wollen aber
wir können nicht denn wir sind abhängig
von den russischen energiereserven was
sich dramatisch finde und womit ich in
diesem ausmaß nicht gerechnet hatte denn
zunächst klang die sanktionen ja sehr
gut der zweite punkt thomas
deutschland setzt sich auch an die
spitze oder beteiligt sich zumindest mit
waffenlieferungen in die ukraine was ich
auch für richtig halte nun haben wir
2700 flugabwehrraketen vom typ strehler
geliefert nach aus nva beständen
beständen aus der ddr stellt sich raus
ein großer teil dieser raketen kann gar
nicht mehr eingesetzt werden ohne
denjenigen der sie einsetzt in gefahr zu
bringen die bundeswehr soldaten die
diese raketen aus dem depot geholt
mussten selber schutzkleidung anziehen
in deutschland weil das depot so
verstümmelt und so schlecht gewartet war
wo diese wichtigen waffen drin lagen
dass es nötig war dass die soldaten sich
selbst geschützt haben auch hier
deutschland will helfen kann es aber
nicht und
gleichzeitig haben wir noch eine anfrage
laufen hier glaube ich ein bisschen aus
dem nähkästchen dessen was die
bild-redaktion gerade stand und leistet
wir haben von bild beim bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz angefragt was sind
eigentlich die szenarien wenn
deutschland angegriffen wird wenn es
dann vielleicht auch zu einem
reaktorunfall kommt denn wir wissen ja
mittlerweile dass die russischen truppen
dass putins truppen auch atomreaktoren
in der ukraine beschossen haben wie sind
da die szenarien wollten wir wissen und
wir bekommen seit tagen keine konkreten
antworten wir haben jetzt habe ich
gerade noch mal mit unseren zuständigen
redakteurin gesprochen wir haben jetzt
eine pro forma antwort bekommen das ist
da aber es sieht überhaupt nicht danach
aus dass in deutschland konkrete
funktionierende pläne für katastrophen
situation wirklich vorliegen und alle
diese drei aspekte die nun für mich nur
die dringlichsten sind man könnte auch
noch weit mehr nennen zeigen mir
eigentlich wie schlecht dieses land das
nun will das sich nun beteiligen will
und seine internationale rolle und
verantwortung gerecht werden möchte wie
schlecht es darauf vorbereitet ist und
wie wenig es kann die szenarien
durchspielen also killerkommandos wird
es nicht geben vielleicht gibt es
konspirative zusammenschlüsse innerhalb
des militärs vielleicht vielleicht aber
auch nicht was bleibt dann noch an
optionen wenn ein nato eingriff zu
gefährlich ist kann man beispielsweise
auf china hoffen china ein wichtiger
player der jetzt ja feststellen muss in
dieser globalisierten welt das
wirtschaftlich sehr an abhängig ist von
internationaler zusammenarbeit wenn wir
uns jetzt nicht in der freien welt
positionieren dann schadet das uns
vielleicht unseren eigenen interessen
werde ich teil absolut thomas sie teile
absolut was herbert gerade gesagt hat
nämlich tötungsaktionen sind sehr
unwahrscheinlich das wäre würde
unweigerlich als ein eingriff eingreifen
des westens in den krieg verstanden
werden und wenn die amerikaner den
russischen präsidenten der nun natürlich
in tirana in diktator geworden ist aber
umbringen würden wäre der dritte
weltkrieg aus meiner sicht
unausweichlich deswegen würde ich das
ausschließen halte es auch für richtig
dass auszuschließen zweite option dass
sich jemand in putins eigenen
machtzirkel gegen ihn stellt würde ich
nicht vollkommen vollständig
ausschließen denn es ist klar dass die
sanktionen direkt beteiligte und auch
extrem mächtige menschen in russland
hart treffen und ich könnte mir auch
vorstellen dass es in russland mächtige
menschen gibt die ein
verantwortungsgefühl für ihr land
empfinden und die auch trotz putins
drastischen propaganda maßnahmen zugang
zur wahrheit haben wissen was vor sich
geht und wo möglich versuchen ein krieg
und eine weitere eskalation von ihrem
eigenen heimatland fernzuhalten
nichtsdestotrotz hat wladimir putin für
viele jahrzehnte sein machtapparat
ausgebaut ist von getreuen umgeben
deswegen glaube ich dass auch hier die
chancen relativ gering sind bleibt die
große diplomatische frage und eben auch
die große militärische frage wie kann
eingegriffen werden wie kann der
konflikt eingedämmt werden oder wie wird
er sich ausweiten ich würde ich dir
sagen das machen tatsächlich fast nichts
ausschließen kann denn in diesem krieg
gibt es ja viele unbekannte und viele
variablen wir sparen bereits darüber
thomas das letzte nacht die russen
angefangen haben die russische armee
angefangen hat auf ein kernkraftwerk zu
schießen in dem moment in dem eine
katastrophe von der dimension die sich
hier kurzzeitig
abgezeichnet hat nämlich eine
kernexplosion
in diesem krieg eine rolle spielt
verschiebt sich das ganze schachbrett
dann halte ich es tatsächlich auch für
möglich dass der westen vielleicht nicht
mit direkten truppen in der ukraine aber
mit anderen stärkeren militärischen
aktionen als allein waffenlieferung in
das spiel rein geht nun hast du auch
china in
das spiel gebracht und ich denke
tatsächlich dass china ein absolut
entscheidender faktor ist teile aber
nicht die hoffnung die ich meine da bei
dir gerade noch anklingen zugehört zu
haben dass sie sich hier um einen
möglicherweise neutralen partner partner
oder vermittler handelt der eben per se
auch ein interesse daran hat
dass das welttheater nicht zu groß wird
denn nach meiner erfahrung und auch bei
allem was wir zum beispiel in hongkong
gesehen haben handelt es sich bei china
um eine diktatur bei der wir im grunde
denselben fehler machen wir als der
westen den der westen lange mit putin
gemacht hat wir reden uns ein so schlimm
ist das alles nicht so wild ist das
alles nicht am ende wollen die geschäfte
machen wir punkten dieses land china
auch mit unserem geld voll wir lassen zu
dass dieses land bei uns investiert und
aus diesen beziehungen ergibt sich
daneben auch die hoffnung nach china da
treiben wir ja viel handel die kennen
wir ja eigentlich die werden sich schon
irgendwie vernünftig neutral verhalten
möglicherweise tun sie es aber selbst
wenn sie es tun tun sie es aus einem
ureigenen egozentrischen kalkül china
ist ein land das von davon ausgeht
selbst anderen länder und überlegen zu
sein china ist ein land das extreme
expansive interessen hat das möchte sich
ausbreiten china ist ein land das selbst
interesse daran hat dass das völkerrecht
das den angriffe auf andere staaten wie
er jetzt in der ukraine erfolgt das
verbietet weniger geld denn china möchte
sich bekanntlich teil waren unter den
nagel reißen und das ist eben eine
schwer vergleichbare weil andere
weltregionen andere länder die hier eine
rolle spielen aber doch irgendwie
aneinander erinnernde situation
wo eine
große macht und china ist ja anders als
russland auch noch im wachsen begriffen
und wird stärker während russland
schwächer wird
eigentlich interesse daran hat geltendes
recht völkerrecht auszuhebeln und
den zugriff auf ein anderes land zu
haben und das durchaus auch mit
waffengewalt und wie wir seit kurzem
wissen eine brillante recherchen der new
york times die wir alle erahnt haben
aber die new york times jetzt zum ersten
mal auch so ausführlich ausgeschrieben
hat ist es ja so dass die russen
regelrecht um erlaubnis in peking
gebeten haben für diese militäraktion in
der ukraine und die antwort war
zusammengefasst etwas vereinfacht könnt
ihr machen aber bitte wartet bis die
olympischen spiele in peking vorbei sind
und ein land das eben sein
einverständnis erklärt hat bei diesem
land auf eine vermittlerrolle zu hoffen
er halte ich für
eine situation in der man sich in dem
man vielleicht der wunsch der vater des
gedanken ist ich rate davon ab dringend
auf china zu setzen bin fest der
überzeugung es geht nur mit westlicher
stärke indem wir extrem aufrüsten das
sind keine schönen wort wörter niemand
möchte das hören also indem wir eben
extreme stärke zeigen damit es uns
gelingt die freiheit des westens und
auch das westliche modelle ballis muss
demokratie individuelle freiheit zu
verteidigen
alle szenarien die wir jetzt durch
gegangen sind sind unsichere szenarien
nichts spricht im moment dafür dass
dieser krieg schnell vorbei ist und
viele menschen auch in deutschland haben
angst dass dieser krieg auch zu uns
kommen könnte dass es einen flächenbrand
geben würde wir berichten hier bei
bild.de seit über einer woche quasi rund
um die uhr ununterbrochen die menschen
zu hause sehen diese bilder des krieges
und dann noch der angriff auf ein
atomkraftwerk in dieser situation
vermisse ich ganz persönlich johannes
eine stimme die auch zu uns spricht zu
uns deutschen bürgern beispielsweise und
meines erachtens könnte dass der gerade
wiedergewählte bundespräsident sein der
richtete seine worte zwar an putin sagt
stoppt diesen krieg das wird nichts
bewirken ist im baltikum unterwegs
spricht mit den nato-partnern das ist
alles wichtig aber wir brauchen
eigentlich auch eine ansprache jetzt in
diesem moment an unsere bürger hier in
deutschland viele von ihnen gerade
ältere die kriege miterlebt haben aber
auch jüngere die überhaupt nicht wissen
was jetzt auf sie zukommt die brauchen
jemanden der jetzt die richtigen worte
findet thomas ich teile deine emotionen
und nicht teile ausdrücklich was du
sagst ich würde mich freuen wenn der
bundespräsident die richtigen worte
findet dass es bislang nicht geschehen
ich bedaure dass ich halte das für
falsch
zumal dem bundespräsidenten gestern noch
ein unglaublicher fauxpas unterlaufen
ist der nun gar nicht im zusammenhang
steht aber auf der webseite seines amtes
des bundespräsidialamtes wurde die
bekannte deutsche terroristin gudrun
ensslin die fracht die in den 80er und
90er jahren in den 80er jahren
deutschland war der baader meinhof
gruppe über der roten armee fraktion
bedroht hat für die für den tod vieler
menschen verantwortlich ist sie wurde
also auf der webseite des
bundespräsidenten als sinngemäß
beeindruckende tolle frau bezeichnet das
war wohl ein fehler aber diese
peinlichkeit kann in diesen stunden
überhaupt niemand gebrauchen und das ist
dem bundespräsidenten nicht gelingt sich
mal an das volk zu wenden wo genau diese
emotionen über die du auch gesprochen
hast ja vorhanden sind gerade ältere
deutsche die sich an den krieg noch
erinnern die sich übrigens auch an einen
krieg mit russland erinnern natürlich
ganz anders gelagert damals war
deutschland der aggressor das dürfen wir
nie vergessen das dürfen wir nie
vergleichen trotzdem die erinnerungen
sind ja präsent dass er da nicht die
richtigen worte finden mit einer
ansprache an das volk die ja auch
deeskalierend sein könnte die auch der
russischen propaganda ein bisschen die
luft aus den reifen lässt das finde ich
extrem bedauerlich und ich frage mich
thomas vielleicht hängt das damit
zusammen dass der präsident aus einer
partei kommt in der man jahrelang dafür
geworben hat näher an russland dran zu
sein die partei die mit der
ministerpräsidentin manuela schwesig die
umstrittene pipeline zugunsten von
russland gebaut hat in der der
altkanzler schröder ist den wiederum der
bundespräsident steinmeier gut kennt und
wie wir wissen
schröder ein enger freund von putin oder
zumindest ein guter bekannter da liegt
etwas im magen und es gibt eben auch
aussagen des bundespräsidenten die ein
paar jahre zurück liegen die dermaßen
von einer blauäugigkeit gegenüber
russland getrieben sind dass ich mich
frage vielleicht gelingt ihm selbst auch
innerlich die kehrtwende noch nicht denn
bei ihm wäre sie ganz klar auch ein
eingestehen der eigenen politischen
fehler in seiner laufbahn als
außenminister und in anderen ämtern die
er in diesem land schon bekleidet hat
johannesburg dank für den besuch ins
studium danke euch